jay mazzini has left the internet this
is his instagram or was his instagram
you can no longer find it either it was
deleted he deactivated it
but this is a gigantic win
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
coffeezilla i am the internet detective
today we're talking about jay mazzini
and uh reflecting on the fact that all
his stuff has sort of been um
taken down by himself by the way it
seems like from what i can tell i think
he just deactivated it
and i'm not even going to say he's going
to be off the internet forever but at
least for now
he can't scam people it's a huge win
listen
i'm not a fan of people taking their
channels offline i'm not a fan of
canceling people and i didn't cancel j
mazzini
i showed what he was doing and he
decided that he didn't want to live on
an internet
where people knew that he was scamming
people but i never said hey go shut this
guy's channel down i never said
hey go get this guy no that's not what
we're about here we're about
shining a light and if you decide that
you don't like the look
of what you're doing on the internet
that's a bad thing that
you should reflect on i mean i don't
know what to tell you
i think that less scammers online
is a good thing and to be clear j
mazzini
it's the worst type of scammer there is
there is a whole
spectrum of the fake guru world right
some of it's very gray and i would argue
like
you couldn't really call it a scam but
you might say uh it's just not worth the
money to me
like a lot of people sell like a 300
course a 500 course and
you know if there's value there but i
just think it's overpriced i'll say
yeah don't really love that whatever
then there's stuff in the middle
where it either doesn't do what they say
it does or it's like
really high price they're pressuring the
upsells like that's bad
usually that's either they don't have
the expertise or it's just like putting
people in the hole and they're not
getting results
then all the way over here is the j
mazzini's of the
world where they're telling people hey
come i'll trade you bitcoin or whatever
and they're just taking money they're
just
basically just theft i don't know
another word for what you might call
that but yeah when you're just taking
people's money they're
not getting anything they're not even
getting like some crappy course they're
literally
having their money taken never returned
uh
and that's disgusting and that i can
draw a hard line in the sand and like
say that society needs
distinctly less of that in reflecting on
the jamazini saga as it winds up this
chapter and we don't know if there's
going to be another chapter
i think it's important to know that a
lot of life is like this okay this is
ponzi schemes explained in the simplest
terms
and just watch it because if you're
falling for the stuff you haven't
learned your lesson okay
this is what it is basically
put something in a dark hole you don't
understand oh look
oh it's a magic machine well it worked
one time i'm gonna throw
everything in halal capital i'll throw
all my money in
oh they gave me more money okay i'm
gonna put my life savings in this thing
so he throws everything underneath what
do you think's gonna happen this is what
you guys do with these influencers who
have no background whatever then it's
yeah you're done they run they shut down
that's like a great metaphor for jay
mazzini
shutting down his instagram he could
flee the country right now nobody would
have any idea
this is something i'm telling you guys
let this learn from other people's
mistakes it's
very sad and we feel terrible for the
victims who this happened to
but you don't have to have the same
thing happen to you okay this channel is
about informing people so they don't
suffer the same
mistakes the same kind of financial loss
as other people you're gonna see on this
channel you do not wanna be
this guy okay it's just the way it is
they're gonna be tons
of things that are promising hey put in
five bucks i gave you five bucks
don't fall for it please so just be a
little more skeptical guys thanks for
watching
pop the stock and i will see you guys
wake up tomorrow the coffee